ام
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم كشفت مجله فورين
بوليسي الامريكي عن ان عمليه استرجاع
مدينه الرمادي من تنظيم الدوله بدات بدايه
متعثره
واكدت وجود خلافات بين قوات الحكومه
ومليشيا الحشد الشعبيه المساند لها يؤثر
على سير العمليات العسكريه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في المحورين
ما هو تاثير الخلافات الطائفيه على عمليه
الانبار ضد تنظيم الدوله
هي حقيقه مخاوف سكان المناطق التي يتم
استردادها من التنظيم
اذن نشرت مجله فورين بوليسي الامريكيه
تحقيقا حول العمليه التي تقوم بها قوات
الحكومه العراقيه وميليشيا الحشد الشعبي
لاستعاده الانبار من تنظيم الدوله في ضوء
زياره الجنرال مارتن ديمبسي رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الاخيره لبغداد ترى
المجله ان العمليه بدات بدايه متعثره
وان الخلافات الطائفيه ضعفها وان معنويات
القوات شديده الانخفاض تهددها وذلك على
الرغم من تفوقه العددي الكبير التقرير
للزميل فتحي اسماعيل
مزيد من كواليس معركه الانبار وانكساراتها
يكشفها الجنرال مارتن ديمبسي وهو يزور
بغداد للمره الاخيره بصفته رئيسا لهيئه
الاركان الامريكيه دون ان تحظى زيارته
باهتمام الاعلام العراقي بلا تحفظ تحدث
الرجل عن الخلافات داخل اروقه القرار وعما
لم تف به الحكومه العراقيه من التزامات
وعن اشياء اخرى يراها سببا في الاخفاق
العسكري ضد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
مجله فورين بوليسي نقلت عن الجنرال
الامريكي قوله عن وجود خلافات داخل حكومه
العباد حول اولويات التحرك حيث يفضل بعض
المسؤولين البدء بالفلوجه قبل الرمادي
وثمه من يعتقد خلاف ذلك لكن الاخطر ربما
هو التباين بشان اي القوات عليها اخذ زمام
المبادره الجيش ام الميليشيات وهو تباين
حال الانقسام الطائفي ويصيب العراق بالشلل
حسب ديمسي الذي قال انه اصيب بخيبه امل من
تقاعس حكومه الاعداد عن الايفاء
بالتزاماتها خاصه فيما يتعلق باعتماد بعض
التشريعات والقوانين وتعيين القاده و
عمليه صنع القرار على نحو زاد منح السكان
السنه الصراع على الادوار والنفوذ بين
الحكومه وميليشيات الحشد الشعبي معروف منذ
الفتوى التي اصدرها السيستاني لكنها وصلت
الى حد تغول تلك الميليشيات باعتراف
العباد نفسه ومحاوله استئثارها بالكلمه
الفصل وان تكون لها اليد العليا حتى على
القوات الحكوميه
لكن يبدو ان ديمسي توصل اوفر بما سماه حلا
وسطا بين تلك الاطراف العراقيه حول اداره
م حركه الرمادي مركز محافظه الانبار
والخاضعه منذ منتصف ايار مايو الماضي ل
سيطره تنظيم الدوله تنص الخطه على ان
تتولى القوات الحكوميه قياده عمليه
استعاده المدينه بينما تفرض الميليشيات
الشيعيه حصارا على مشارف الفلوجه لخلق
خطوط الامداد الرئيسيه للتنظيم ثم ياتي
دور متطوعي العشائر السنيه الذين بداوا
اخيرا في تلقى التدريب والاسلحه من
الولايات المتحده للانتشار لاحقا في
الرمادي مما قد يساعد على طمانه السكان
المحليين لكن هل ستسير الامور كما يراد
لها فعلا في ضوء تجارب سابقه منيت فيها
القوات العراقيه بالهزيمه رغم تفوقها في
العدد والعتاد وهو ما دفع وزير الدفاع
الامريكي الى وصفها بال مفتقده لاراده
القتال
موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقشه مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور لقاء مكي الكاتب
والباحث السياسي العراقي من بغداد محمد
العديلي عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون
ومن لندن الدكتور غسان العطيه مدير المعهد
العراقي للتنميه والديمقراطيه نرحب
بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا من بغداد السيد محمد
العقيلي عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون
سيد محمد نود ان نعرف بدايه
معك مع زياده الاحاديث الخلافات بين قوات
الحشد الشعبي
وقوات الجيش العراقي لمن الكلمه الفصل من
يملك الكلمه النهائيه
شكرا جزيلا تحيه الى الضيوف الكرام والى
مشاهديكم الاكارم لك سيدتي الكريمه اعتقد
الكلمه الفصل في قياده العمليات والتحرك
ال بوضع الخطط والتحرك التكتيكي هو من
مهمه القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ومن ثم تعطي الاوامر الى
الفصائل المسلحه العراقيه التابعه الى
القوات العراقيه المركزيه وكذلك الى فصائل
ال حيث الشعبي المسانده الى القوات
العراقيه وهي قوات عراقيه صرفه مائه
بالمائه حتى تتلقى الاوامر من القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه بموجب
الاتفاق ما بين الكتل السياسيه داخل مجلس
الوزراء وتم التصويت داخل مجلس الوزراء
العراقي الذي يضم كل الاطياف السياسيه او
كل الطيف السياسه العراقيه على ان الحج
الشعبي هو مرتبط بالحكومه العراقيه وجزء
من الاراده للدوله العراقيه هذا جانب
الجانب الثاني هناك معطيات ايجابيه تلقتها
منظومه الحشد الشعبي ومنظومه القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه بصوره عامه هو ان
هناك اه قبول اه رسمي من قبل مجلس محافظه
الانبار ب دخول الحشد الشعبي الى محافظه
الانبار
قبل ان ندخل في التفاصيل هناك ما يتحدث عن
صراع حقيقي
الارادات والنفوذ وحتى على الابواب بين
ميليشيات الحشد الشعبي والقوات الحكوميه
نفسه واعترف بذلك وقال بانها يعني هناك
محاولات الاستقطاب بالتالي منفصل وان تكون
لها اليد العليا حتى على القوات الحكوميه
يعني بالتاكيد هناك من يريد ان يشوه سمعه
الحج الشعبيه ومن ريد العباده
لا لا ابدا ارجو ان تفهميني بالط بالطريقه
الصحيحه هناك من يريد لكن السيد العبادي
اشهر على هذه المناطق والمكان الخطره على
الحج الشعبي ومنظومه الدوله العراقيه ووضع
الحلول الكفيله بالحد والمنع من هذه من
هذه الجهات التي تريد ان تتقمص شخصيه الحج
الشعبي بالاعتداء المواطنين وان تكون هناك
تشويه الحشد الشعبي الحشد الشعبي لا توجد
فيه صراع الارادات هناك الاراده الحكوميه
للدوله العراقيه
هى من تتحكم فى المجاميع المتطوعه والحديث
الشعبي ل تساند القوات الامنيه العراقيه
لذلك حققت انتصارات كبيره في عده مناطق في
في عده مناطق عده مواطن في
الشعب العراقي خصوصا
العطيه ضيفنا من لندن ان مثل هذا الكلام
الذي تسمع اذن القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه هو من يحكم الكلمه الاولى
والاخيره له هو هناك محاولات فقط لتشويه
قوات الحشد الشعبي
ولا حديث حقيقي على الاقل ليست هناك ادله
وفق ما يقول ضيفنا من بغداد على وجود اي
خلافات بين الطرفين
الشكر
ما تفضل به الاخ الكريم يعبر عن وجد طرف
سياسي في الحكومه وهو طرف داعم ومتحمس
للحديث الشعبي ما يواجه العبادي والحكومه
الحاليه ان هذه المعركه يجب ان لا تتكرر
ما حصل في تكريت وبالتالي صحيح استرجعوا
الارض ولكنها خسر السكان البشر اثنين
الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان تقحم نفسها
في حرب طائفيه وبالتالي لا تريد ان تحسب
على ضبط طرف ضد اخر
فهي لا تريد ان تصر السنه ولا تريد ان
تقتل الشيعه وبذلك تحاول ان يكون النصر او
استرجاع الاراضي يؤدي الى تعزيز الوحده
الوطنيه العراقيه وهذا لا يتم الا من خلال
كسب قلوب
وعقول ابناء المنطقه اقولها بكل صراحه
ابناء المناطق المحافظات العربيه السنيه
ابنائهم غالبيتهم العظمى العظمى الكبير
جدا هي تخشى الحديد الشعبي وتفضل اه ان
يكون الجيش العراقي هو راس الرمح خاصه وان
الجيش العراقي يضم شيعه وسنه وكردي واذا
كانوا في السابق تكون بالجيش فهم الان
يرضون بالجيش لانهم لا يريدوا ان تاتي
زعامات شيعيه باسم الحشد والسيطره على
مناطق هناك نعم هناك بعض الشيوخ بعض ال
الابناء يتعاطف ويكون الشعب يدخل لكن
هؤلاء بالنسبه الى الراي العام العربي
السني مرفوض وتكلم من معلومات مباشره من
العدو الحل العملي الان
معركه الرمادي تضع مكانه السيد عبادي على
المحك كما تضع مكانه الولايات المتحده على
المحك الجنرال دم سي وهو رئيس الاركان
وتنتهي ولايه تبعتكم شهر هذا الرجل كان في
بغداد من الفين وخمسه وسبعه وعمل على
تدريب الجيش هذا القائد هو الذي قال قبل
اسابيع بعد
هزيمه
سقوط الانباء الرمادي بان ما حصل ليس طردا
للجيش العراقي وانما انسحاب الجيش العراقي
اي هو خرج من المنطقه دون ان يقاتل الان
مجيئه الى بغداد مجيء رئيسا لهيئه الاركان
يعني ان هناك مشكله مشكله ليسمع بين
القوات الامريكيه نفسها مشكله بين الحكومه
وبين القوات
الى النقطه مهمه اذن هناك مشكله حقيقيه
بين القوات الحكوميه وقوات الحشد الشعبي
حتى وان لم يعترف بها الطرف الاخر اللقاء
الان يعني هذه الخلافات او هذه المشكله
كما وصفها الدكتور العطيه كيف تؤثر على
سير العمليات هناك من يرى تخبط حتى مثل ما
قال
وان كان هناك
هو بالحقيقه
خلاف يبدو على مع الحكومه العراقيه حول
اولويات الاهداف ال المعلومات المتسربه من
مصادر مطلعه وكما ايضا اشارت لها الفريق
وسيعرض ان هذا اليوم اه تتعلق بان
الامريكان كانوا يريدون استهداف الرمادي
قبل الفلوجه ولذلك الجيش العراقي وزاره
الدفاع التزمت في هذا الاتفاق مع
الاميركان لكن ال حيث الشعبي اعطى
الاولويه للفلوجه طبعا الامريكان لديهم
اسباب عسكريه واستراتيجيه معنويه ذات بعد
المعنوي اولا رمادي اسلحه العسكريه
ثانيا الفلوجه لها هي الرمزيه معنويه
كبيره لدى العرب السنه اولا هي يعني حاربت
الامريكان مرتين في احد اهم انتصرت على
المارين اه لديها رمزيه خاصه في وسط
العراق وبالتالي كسرها
وتدبيرها اه ربما سيؤثر على المعنويات
يعني يجعل السنه يتحفظون ضد الحكومه ومع
التنظيم لا سيما وان فيها مدنيين مازالوا
فيها الاف العوائل لذلك كان الاميركان
يفضلون الرمادي تقريبا المدنيين اقل فيها
من على الفلوجه اللي حصلنا الحج الشعب
يركز على الفلوس وفقط ركز وانما حتى
التصريحات صدرت من قيادات والحج الشعبي
احدهم قال العيد في الفلوجه الاخر قاليه
رئيس الافعال الاخر توعد بتدميرها وهذه
التصريحات يعني نقلت عن السنتهم قاده كبار
منهم نائب رئيس الهيئه تعملها يعني حق
الشعب اه ولذلك نرى التخبط ان الحج الشعب
يركز على الفلوجه الجيش في مكان ثاني لكن
هذا السجال يعني باعتقادك هل هو اه
استراتيجي يعني ايهما نبدا فيها انها له
ابعاد اخرى
لا لا
يعني سيد العلي يتحدث عن سيطره القائد
العام هو الرجل يريد لكنه لا يستطيع قضيه
الان مثلا ايران قامت جسر مباشر بالعلاقه
بينها وبين ميليشيات داخل الحزب الحشد لم
ينشا بقرار دستوري عراقي الحشد انشاء
بفتوى من المرجعيه الدينيه المرجعيه
الدينيه ليس السلطه دستوريه في العراق هي
مرجعيه لفئه و طائفه معينه في العراق فقط
ولذلك فهو ان شيء في حاله حرب ولم ينظم
كقوه مسلحه ما زالت كثير من من الفصائل
الاشياء داخل الحشد مرتبطه عضويه تسليح يا
وفكريا واستراتيجيه وعسكريين بايران ولذلك
لا يمكن ان تاخذ اوامرها من القائد العام
هذا الكلام لا يصدقه عقل ال اللي حصل
اليوم مثلا قبل ما دخل الاستوديو بقليل
ورد خبر انه الحج الشعبي احرق ثلاثه اشخاص
احياء في ديالا وخلي سيدي يتاكد ان اعرف
هذا الخبر الج قبل قليل
ولانهم اه اعتقلوا بتهمه اه زرع عبوه ماشي
يعني تحاكم ويحرقون امام الماره وامام
الجيش في المناسبه في نقطه تفتيش طيب هذا
الفلتان ل لضبط اذا كان صحيح وهناك حوادث
كثيره يعني متكرره هذا هو الخطير الذي
يجعل القائد العام غرب
القاعده عن غير مسيطره على
البدالين هذه التجاوزات الموجوده سيد محمد
العقيلي يعني غير ذلك التصريحات التي
نسمعها هذا السجال اصلا الرمادي اولا
الفلوجه اولا هناك من هناك تخبط حقيقه جدا
يصير ان يتحدث عن ما يشبه خطه او اتفاق
على ان قوات الحكومه هاجم الرمادي
المليشيات تحاصر الفلوجه والمتطوعون السنه
بعد ذلك ينتشرون في المدينه اصلا هذه
الخطه الا يشتم منها رائحه طائفيه اصلا
بالاساس والى اي مدى يمكن ان تصمد على
الارض و يمكن تطبيقها
توجد هناك دوافع طائفيه اذا كان التوجه
باتجاه الفلوجه او التوجه الرمادي لكن
هناك تنسيق على المستوى ما بين الحشد
الشعبي الذي تطور ادائه الى مستويات عليا
وحتى قاده المعارك والانتصارات باوقات
قياسيه حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قالت ان القضاء على داعش يحتاج
بخصوص قوات الحاجز
يعني ابدا انا يعني اتشرف ان انقل وجهه
نظر الحكومه ودافع عن الحكومه العراقيه ان
الحكومه ومنتخب الحكومه الشرعيه واستخرجت
وردت من الصندوق الانتخابى الديمقراطي
الشرعي بخلاف بعض البلدان التي لديها
دكتاتوريه لكن انا لست متاكدا واسكن في
الخارج
تاتي ان يكيل التهم اتجاه الحج الشعبي انا
اعتقد اليوم من يكيل التهم عليه ان يثبت
بالدليل القاطع لان هذه ارواح الناس يعني
اتهام الى اشخاص وناس يحققون انتصارات
كبيره ويحررون المناطق المختص به من داعش
اليوم علينا ان نساند الحج الشعبي بما انه
لديه نوايا طيبه ونوايا لتحرير البلاد
والعباد من قبضه ارهابيه قاتله الى الحياه
والانسانيه بالتالي علينا وان كانت هناك
فوات وان كانت هناك اخطاء وبالتالي هي
اخطاء غير غير اه استراتيجيه نعم في جيوش
تكون هناك حالات فرديه لكن ليس بالضروره
ان تنسحب على الاداء الجماعي او الاداء
للقرار هذا جانب الجانب الاخر هناك
التنسيق العالي اعطيت المهمه الى الحج
الشعبي ان يعني يقطع الامداد عن مدينه
الفلوجه لانها تعتبر الفلوجه هي طبعا هي
راس الافعى ليس للسكان الفلوجه لان
الفلوجه فيها الدواعش ونقصد هنا
الافعى على الدواعش ليس لسكان الفلوجه
الذين هم عراقيون اصلاء و محط اهتمام
ومحطه احترام من قبل القياده العراقيه ومن
قبل حتى الشعب العراقي ومن قبل الحج
الشعبي الذي يعطي الدماء في سبيل تحرير
الفلوجه هكذا يعامل من يعطي دمائه لتحرير
المناطق العراقيه هذا سؤال مهم يفترض ان
يجيب عليه الاخوه الذين يشككون بالحج
وقدرات الحاجه الشعبي
اليوم
تحدث عن نواياه الطيبه للحشد الشعبي
تقابلها
لكن على الارض وفي الواقع تخوفات حقيقيه
من سكان المناطق التي التي يتم استعدادها
من تنظيم الدوله وسنتحدث في الجزء الثاني
طبعا عن هذه المخاوف الانس نذهب الى فاصل
قصير بعدها اذا سنناقش موضوع ال مخاوف
السكان الانبار من تاثير هذه الخلافات
الطائفيه عليهم نعود بعد قليل
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الخلافات بين قوات الحكومه العراقيه
ومليشيا الحشد الشعبيه وتاثيرها على عمليه
السعاده الانبار مره اخرى نعود الى ضيوفنا
الكرام الى لندن والدكتور غسان العطيه
هناك مخاوف حقيقيه الان حتى من عمليات
انتقام طائفيه من قبل سكان اه الانبار
باعتقاده الى اي مدى لها ما يبررها بالنظر
لحوادث واه اشياء يعني حدثت سابقا من قبل
او تجاوزات حدث سابقا من قبل قوات الحشد
الشعبي
انه تمشي نفسها قال في لقاء قبل اه اسابيع
بان الاشكال في العراق هو الانقسام
الطائفي
والشيء المهم ان ابناء هذه المناطق التي
تتمركز فيها داعش واللي فيها حواضن داعش
يجب ان يشعروا ابناء تلك المنطقه ان
الحكومه تمثلهم وان يدافع عن الحكومه
وبالتالي ينحاز والحكومه والدم اللي حصل
الى الان ان من اجل المعركه السياسيه
المعركه ستنجح واعتقد معظم العراقيين
يريدون نجاح الحكومه وال داعش لكن السؤال
ماذا بعد داعش يبدو ان داعش بدا توحد
العراقيين عربا وكردا وشيعه وسنه وتركمان
قسمت هم الطرف الكردي كانت داعش بالنسبه
الى لوضع ايده على المناطق التي اعتبرها
كرديه وهذا ما حققت الان الطرف الشيعي
يعتقد انها فرصه وهنا انقسم الطرف الشيعي
قسم وجد انه لابد من ذراع شيعي فقط فبدا
الحشد عمليا شيعي بالتالي ال رد الفعل عند
الطرف العربي السني هو التخوف وعدم قدره
ال اه ابناء المناطق الحكومه ليست لحكومه
وانما جمع حكومه عدم قدره ان تكسب ثقه
ابناء المحافظات السنيه يعرقل العمليه
العسكريه و يخافوا من هذه النتيجه والمهم
بالموضوع ليس الادعاءات وانما الواقع
الملموس وهو الانتظار يحرك الناس اكثر من
معرفه التفاصيل هنا يبدو واضح ان الولايات
المتحده لمست بالملموس من شخصيات اه
المحافظات هذه ومن غيرها ان العمليه
العسكريه في حال نجاحها لا تريد تبديد
نجاح ل لاسترجاع الرماديه صالح اه اه
حكومه اه توحد العراقيين لا حكومه ينتصر
لها طرف الطرف الاخر هذه المعادله
مؤخرا العمليه وانا اعتقد الاخوان بال
وتلقى او غيرهم مخلصين ويريدون فعلا لكن
السؤال اذا انت تريد تحرر الرمادي لماذا
لا تشارك ابناء الرمادي نفسه لماذا لم
تشرع قانون الحرس الوطني اللي للانصار سنه
في الدوليه لماذا لا تتعامل و تتحدث معهم
عمليا لماذا لم تطبق ال البرنامج السياسي
اللي اتفق عليه بتشكيل حكومه الان الكره
الحقيقه في ملعب الشيعي السياسي الاسلامي
تحافظ على وحده العراق
انا انا المحافظه على حدود في العراق
عليها اشراك كل ابناء العراق اللقاء نوايا
طيبه يقول السيد محمد العديلي الذي يقول
في الواقع
والله انا لا استطيع ال الحكم على النوايا
نوايا السياسيين
يعني لا يعملون بالنوايا ويعملون
بالقرارات والمواقف نوايا هذه في علاقاتنا
الشخصيه بين شخص واخر نحنا نتحدث عن
مستقبل البلد ومصادر لملايين العراقيين
وربما مستقبل المنطقه
الحقيقه اولا لم تصدر حتى الان للحكومه
العراقيه اي مبادره حقيقيه واقعيه
اه يمكن ان نقول انها تريد فعلا التوحيد
العراقي حتى الان لم نسمع شوي الكلام
والبعض يتكلمون على الارض من خلال الحركات
العسكريه ايضا الواقع يقول ما يبرر هذه
التخوفات التي نسمعها الانبار هو شوفي
خلال الفتره الاخيره بعد ظهور داعش
بالتاكيد الانقسام الطائفي كبر بالمنطقه
كلها وفقت في واصبح عنوان للصراع القضيه
الطائفيه ولذلك فهي ليست حكرا على العراق
وهذا اصبح واقع حال اذا اردنا انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه والتوحد في محاربه هذا
التنظيم الخطير والمناسبه ولا يمكن انه
يحصل الفلوجه لكن يربح في منطقه اخرى يضر
في منطقه اخرى ويفوز لانه المشكله عندها
ليست مشكله ارض هذا تنظيم ميليشياوي يعني
يطلع من هذه الارضيه وحرب اخرى هي ليست
معركه حدود مع دوله المهم انه اذا كان
هناك رغبه بت واحد العراقيين فيجب ان تكون
هناك مبادره حقيقيه والمبادره ليست تفضل
من الحكومه على الاخرين بل هي محاوله
للتقرب الى وسط الطريق مع الاخرى تقديم
تنازلات جديه واتخاذ قرارات صعبه العمر
يتعلق بهذا المستقبل وبالمناسبه الخساره
على الجميع بما فيهم الذين هم الان في
السلطه يعني حتى ان قسم من ثلاث دقائق
الاخيره السيد محمد العقيلي ما رايك اذن
يجب تقديم تنازلات الطرف الاخر مستعده
لتقديم هذه التنازلات من اجل الحل في
اقل من دقيقه لو تكرمت اه حقيقه هو السؤال
التنازلات الامام التنازلات هم والاخوه
السنه ال اذا كان السيد اللقاء
تقاطع
الحكومه العراقيه قدمت البرنامج الحكومي
الذي هو كان محطه للاتفاق ما بين كل كل كل
كل كل الكتل السياسيه التي شكلت شكره من
عده الحكومه الحد الان نسب متقدمه بانجاز
البرنامج الحكومي والقرارات من مجلس
الوزراء هو خير دليل على ذلك النوايا
اللقاء يقول لا حكم عن نوايا طيب تحرير
المناطق اللي حررت من قبضه داعش والان
الاهالي يرجعون الى تكريت والى العلم والى
البو عجيل والى مناطق اخرى من جرف الصخر
ومن امري كلها هذه افعال تصادق مع النوايا
ليس النوايا التي هي من الممكن لا نحكم
عليها نحكم على الافعال والانتصارات هذا
الجانب الجانب الاخر اهالي الانبار الذين
ذاقوا الامرين
العمريه من قبل داعش هم الان يعني في
احتضان وفي احضان ابنائهم من الوسط
والجنوب وحتى بغداد وفي رعايه من قبل
الحكومه العراقيه
المصالحه وتوحيد الانتصارات بالمناسبه حفظ
الامن الميليشيات هذا واجبات اساسيه
للدوله العراقيه
لا تفضل بها على الناس ان فشلت فيها فهذا
عليها وان نجحت فيها فهذا لا يحسب لها لا
نواصل جزء من واجباتها وبالتالي اي خلل
يحصل اللي بيقدر يسيطر على الامور يطلع
غيره لكن انا اتحدث عن مشروع اكبر من هذه
القضيه مثل ما قال الاستاذ غسان ماذا بعد
داعش يجب ان نخلق الان بيئه ل انتصار
حقيقي على صعيد جسم الانسان وليس فقط رد
طبعا من ضيوفي الكرام ان احس وانه لم يكن
هنالك انصاف في الوقت عن وقتنا للاسف
الشديد انتهت مع من اشهر الجديد ضبط
اللقاء الكاتب الباحه السياسيه العراقيه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر
من بغداد محمد
الى دوله القانون ومن لندن اشكر الدكتور
غسان العطيه مدير المعهد العراقي للتنميه
والديمقراطيه
ختام حلقتنا هذا التقرير
السلام عليكم
ام